just a warning that my topic does
contain language that some viewers might
find offensive the professional
footballers Association has agreed with
Manchester forward Raheem Sterling that
negative press coverage in Bolden's
racist rhetoric against young black
footballers Chelsea and the police are
investigating Sterling's claims that he
was racially abused during their game
against City according to figures from
anti-discrimination charity kick it out
reports of discriminatory abuse in
football increased 11% last season a
sixth successive annual rise now I
remember growing up fearing football at
the age of 10 I made the mistake of
asking school colleagues if I could join
their game I was punched hard in the
stomach and told this game's not for
pakis I never played seriously again by
the time we became teenagers ethnic
minorities were petrified of matchday
and would avoid stadiums from fear of a
racist mob I had thought that those bad
old days were long behind us but the
demon of discrimination is returning
this must not be tolerated press or
social media whatever the cause all of
us must push back against the scourge of
racism our game our democracy and our
country are stronger together
[Music]
I mean it does appear that this ability
to say the scourge of racism is
reappearing in football we seem to have
disappeared almost although I used to
say that you know when I was chairman of
the FA and people used to say oppor to
sit in the boardroom you know you're not
on the terraces you don't know what's
being said and what's not being said I
mean if it is as serious as it gets more
serious and gets more worrying you've
got to look and say what what can the
football authorities do about it and
I've thought long and hard and I think
how do you make football supporters
really understand that they shouldn't
happen well if you deducted points from
the from the clubs which the clubs would
hate the Premier League when I don't
make I just work Chelsea scarf and in
fact I'm at Leicester City fan and I
make sure I get those three points well
you know you've got to be investigated
well yeah but then the problem is do you
not and I'm clearly glad you started I'm
sorry to talk over you but the FA said
nothing the Premier League said nothing
you ran the FA would you have said
something
oh yeah we devote well why nothing
without what you'd have said it's
unacceptable because there's now an
investigation going on into though it
wasn't some day a month went to those
into those particular fans shamefully
what is it about the terraces in
particular that seems to attract these
things above and beyond other sports
yeah I think what is it I think there
becomes brutally competitive I think for
some people it is effectively their
religion it's been handed on from their
grandfathers through their father so
they feel it so passionately so there's
probably that it used to be it used to
be a sort of working-class sport I think
you would attest to that great whether
it is now with the sort of money you
have to pay
I very much doubt it but and I know we
can't talk about too much we can't show
you the picture I get that for legal
reasons but if a paint picture paints a
thousand words that picture of mr.
Stirling laughing in the face of that
racism 500 of those thousand words for
me was how great it is that you had the
courage to do that because if you can
point at laughs at potentially vile
people like that that is half of the way
forward so I thought he did brilliantly
they have released a statement
subsequently subsequently yes um I wrote
my first ever newspaper article when I
was 14 and it was about the then-new
launched kick it out campaign to end
wolf it was for the boys newspaper I
started journalism when I was still at
school oh you and I remember speaking
then this was 1995 to premier league
football was like I interviewed some
footballers at QPR who are talking about
the daily racist abuse they get and I
had friends then who were footballers
who were teenagers who played whoo it
was just a regular thing that they would
get racist apiece and you know I was
talking to somebody who mentors a lot of
young footballers this morning he was
telling me that it's still standard for
black boys up and down the country to
get racist abuse when they play away
matches sometimes at home sometimes from
fans sometimes from their teammates or
their teammates families and you know
the thing for me listening to this is
that everyone is surprised you know this
never disappeared and just no one was
listening if you speak to any black boy
who's been playing shuttle it's
something they've been going through and
the other thing I want to say cuz I
think we all quite consoled sit here and
say this is bad and it's outrageous an
apology should be made and legal
proceedings should be carried out which
they seem to be in the process of doing
but the other part - your your topic
major was the role of the media the role
of the media in doing this I just want
to show you something here are some
examples of headlines about Rahim stone
yeah here we go so obscene Rahim who had
the audacity to buy a nice house I know
Premier League football Zev Urdu he then
was frugal enough to buy clothes from
Primark which is clearly outrageous and
then he had the nerve to eat breakfast
and finally last but not least he bought
hold the front page a flashy car
footballers do this day in day out you
can't deny that Raheem Sterling's been
singled out and treated differently by
the media and it's been really adjusting
for me to listen to people like John
Barnes who I used to watch playing and
being racially abused when I was a
teenager coming out this week and saying
how strongly he feels and we heard other
Premier League football saying this that
the way that the media the narrative the
tone around not just black footballers
but people of color in this be in this
country in general contributes to this
debate and I want to say this coz around
this table we've sat here and talked
about coverage of Asian pedophiles and
I'm using the term that's using the
media coverage of black gangs and knife
crime
and we racialized crime when it relates
to black people in a way that demonizes
them when white people commit crime it's
just crying it's just pedophiles it's
just violence and so we can we
perpetuate these ideas that have
penetrated people's consciousness that
there is something unique about ethnic
minority people that makes them criminal
or depraved or violent and it's no
subscrible of the same attitude I want
to come to Michele but here are the two
that the point you were referring yes
these are the ones Rahim put on his own
Instagram page and it's the comparison
between two footballers one black one
white of course there is buying house is
criticized for never having started a
Premier League match yet splashing up
money on a house and yet the white
player is praised for buying a house for
his mom that that's the two images that
I assume that's a stretch belt
how much I want to say on this topic
because when I was a child football was
a very dominant force for one of a
better word throughout my whole
childhood because of my father's
relationship with it my father tried to
orchestrate a play a buy out our local
to the whole city and it was even our
house was painted in black enamel which
is the color I'm not even kidding the
bin and the wheel not the wheelie bin
but the bin and everything so football
was such a prominent thing as a
consequence hooliganism was also quite a
thing that I was exposed to a lot as
their child and there's always been
because I used to go to the Kempton it
was called that the stone was the
council approve free park and there's
always been from as long as I can
remember I associate football with fan
violence rightly or wrongly so I would
go to let's just say the rugby I would
go to a derby rugby Dhabi and I would
happily go to a pub with the other teams
supporters and I would wear whatever
team I'm supporting his colours and I
would feel no mammies I'd feel no stress
I'd feel relaxed in that pub when you go
to a pub in advance of football match
like if I think of hold this those pops
wear away supporters you're just not
allowed in because they have to
physically segregate those fans so there
is something about the game of football
that brings out and it's not just about
racism and racist abuse not 2/9 that
happens but it brings our primitive
violent
predominately within men but it's got
better it has got better but now what
you don't know is that got better
because the police just organized it
better so that the tool that you need is
visible it's very primal it's very
tribal but I would it's your word of
caution having selected this debate I
think I worry that if we are if if the
level is constantly at red alert if we
are constantly act sort of we're on ten
if out of a scale of naught to 10 we're
at level ten constantly then it's boy
cries wolf or people don't actually
believe it when it happens so I think we
have to accept that it did wane for a
bit it wasn't as bad I've said this to
before I think it's slightly younger
than me slightly not too much I'm not
too old but it did actually in our days
it was a lot worse than I imagined when
you were coming of age but it seems to
me to be coming let's just say it's not
I mean plenty of people can go watch a
game this Saturday or Sunday there are
statistics about the level of violence
that's recurring and racism and keep it
out of documenting a rise which means it
kind of waned for me they're saying
year-on-year it's getting worse and
they've documented an 11 percent rise of
racial different because you think it's
tribal because the middle class sport by
and large and football does it work but
you know coming on to the points you're
making about it being tribal and it's
it's a space as we know where certain
versions of masculinity seems to get
expressed if that's all the symptom to
me it's a symptom not a cause it just so
happens that when you get football
matches and groups of men especially
with emotion being expressed in ways
that often isn't it provides a space in
which things that are always there but I
usually aren't usually expressed come
out so it's not because there's
something uniquely racist about football
fans these are views that are cultural
they are penetrates deep into our
society it's just that this is the time
when we see them and that's why I think
it's important to move the conversation
away from saying what's wrong with all
these football fans saying what is it
about our society that allows these
medieval ideas to thrive because they're
still there that's human beings I think
they have a specific history imagine
though